nuevo bloque de economía en directo
américa ya está nuevamente en el estudio
daniela blandón daniela vamos a empezar
hablando de méxico hay buenas y malas
noticias en el mercado laboral empecemos
con la buena hola raul buenos días de
nuevo pues la buena es que el instituto
nacional de estadística
dice que la tasa de desempleo bajó al
4.2 por ciento esto en el tercer
trimestre de 2021 la cifra es menor que
hace un año cuando superó el 5% pero
sigue estando por encima del nivel pre
pandémico y quiere decir que 2.5
millones de personas están sin empleo en
este país cuando en el peor momento de
la pandemia unos 12 millones de personas
llegaron a abandonar la fuerza laboral
ahora veamos cuál es el verdadero
problema de méxico y es la informalidad
que hoy alcanza el 53 por ciento de la
fuerza laboral en este caso los 31,4
millones de personas que trabajan en
precarias condiciones son más de los que
había hace un año y también de los que
había antes de la pandemia raúl el
centro de estudios económicos del sector
privado dice que todavía queda una gran
brecha laboral
unos 17 6 millones de empleos formales
esto quiere decir que se necesita crear
esos puestos de tiempo completo y
también bien remunerados para satisfacer
las necesidades de los hogares danny
ahora vamos a hablar de chile y le
pregunto cómo reaccionaron los mercados
luego de las elecciones primarias del
pasado domingo pues sabemos que fueron
unos comicios bastante reñidos entre las
posiciones de izquierda y de derecha
pero el mercado financiero lo tomó
relativamente bien la bolsa chilena
experimentó el lunes o en su mayor alza
en 13 años su principal indicador el
ipsa se disparó en 9 69 por ciento como
no subía desde octubre de 2008 en plena
crisis financiera mundial veremos cómo
abre el día de hoy contrario a este
resultado el dólar tuvo un proceso de un
retroceso mejor de 17,3 pesos frente a
la divisa chilena pero llegó a caer
inclusive el doble un dólar hoy vale 811
pesos chilenos y este es el peor dato de
desvalorización en dos años ahora dan y
porque la bolsa sube y el dólar baja
pues parece que al mercado le conviene
más que él hasta josé antonio kast
llegué al poder porque es un programa es
más puro mercado y también plantea
continuar con el modelo neoliberal y eso
hace que los inversionistas estén en
relativamente más tranquilos y conserven
sus activos en el país y si hay más
dólares circulando en la economía pues
el precio tiende a subir el del dólar y
a bajar el del peso chileno otra noticia
económica en chile raúl en medio de la
euforia electoral el parlamento aprobó
la ley de presupuesto para 2022 por 82
mil millones de dólares que contempla un
recorte del 22,5 por ciento en el gasto
público seguimos hablando de subidas y
bajadas pero hablemos de una caída
porque caen las ventas de la vivienda en
reino unido bueno mira se vendieron 76
mil viviendas en octubre eso tampoco es
una mala cifra pero si representan la
mitad de lo que se había vendido en
septiembre y esto tiene una explicación
y es que hubo una exención fiscal que
estuvo vigente hasta septiembre que
buscaba alentar la compra de viviendas
durante la crisis del cob y 19 desde el
año pasado el gobierno de boris johnson
había eliminado hasta julio de este año
uno de los impuestos sobre los primeros
600 73 mil dólares que costará la
vivienda en inglaterra e irlanda del
norte esta medida siguió vigente hasta
septiembre pero con sobre la mitad de
ese monto sea heras a julio y hasta
septiembre se amplió pues los
compradores decidieron aprovechar esta
oferta impositiva y ahora se quedaron
sin esa extensión por eso ya se están
vendiendo menos viviendas aunque los
precios siguen disparados por cuenta de
las clases de estas unidades
habitacionales le pregunté entonces
ahora daniela por los indicadores bueno
pues el peso sobre las bolsas en la
designación en que hizo del presidente
yo bailén de llevo powell como
presidente de la reserva federal para
que continúe su mandato las bolsas de se
mueven entonces al ritmo de este
nombramiento en las acciones europeas
caen a mínimos de tres semanas y se
preparan para su peor sesión en casi dos
meses los inversionistas ven la
permanencia de paul como una señal de
que pronto comenzarán a subir las tasas
de interés en asia por su parte se
hundió el índice hang seng por el
pesimismo que hay de los inversionistas
sres al sector tecnológico daniela y
quien nos trae como cifra el día ya para
despedir la economía por el día de hoy 2
884 millones de dólares que fueron las
ganancias de la plataforma suma entre
febrero y octubre de este año esto es el
doble de lo que registró en el mismo
período de 2007 y es que a su nadie lo
conocidas de dos años y ya se convirtió
en uno de los símbolos más
característicos de esta pandemia así es
tener y usted ha hecho fiesta por su
vida yo confesé que mi cumpleaños yo
pasé por ahí entendimiento sólo quiero
saber si se toma unos vinitos con sus
amigas por su hice uno solo y decidí
jamás volverlo a hacer porque mal
experience no me gusta borracho no es
muy personal
daniela gracias entonces por toda la
información nos vemos a mañana con más
economía vamos ahora a parís